so I November I man mutters courage is
in Los Angeles for this year's la car
show he's very happy to be there first
because in Germany it would most likely
be gray and damp and also because there
are plenty of new models here for his
Christmas list first ND some 50
brand-new cars are debuting here 20 are
celebrating their world premieres but
there are also facelifted versions of
cars that have long been on the market
these are especially for car buyers
they've come to the show in droves it's
not limited to professionals there are
more models here ready for production
than at other car shows like the new
mini for example daanish muzzle climb
them mutters points out that the new
countryman is hardly mini he examines a
clever new feature he didn't quite
understand at first he thought the
cushion was meant to protect the bumper
while loading or unloading the car but
this didn't quite make sense it's
actually for sitting on if the driver
wants to take a rest in the open air or
take off dirty walking boots and to
change into cleaner shoes to keep the
inside spotless position is clever this
feature thanks to the Lincoln Navigator
concept car you can forget your house
keys and still have a clean outfit for
the next day Volkswagen is aiming to
become the world leader for electric
drive cars over the next 10 years
they've just unveiled a new eGolf
dividing up your good stock mount
explains that the car has fifty percent
more range than before this amounts to
125 miles of driving before the battery
needs to be recharged so clients can
drive back and forth to work for several
days in a row this makes it far more
practical than before I'm not
hood what makes it different from the
conventional gulf is the electric motor
sleeker body design and various details
the battery charger is under the fuel
cap so it doesn't take up space in the
trunk
in the creation mythology montes
explains that in Greek mythology Atlas
held up the heavens Volkswagen hopes
that its new atlas will prop up north
american sales matas thinks that this
full-size SUV was far too long reaching
the market he definitely wants it on his
Christmas list Mazda's new compact SUV
is somewhat smaller it boasts the same
elegant Kodo design that the Japanese
company first introduced in its cx-5 a
few years ago the contours of the next
generation model are much more owned
it's due out in the first half of 2017
under the holga is Bernard Kaplan from
mazda explains to the familiar motor
lineup under the hood remains what's
changed and improved are the driver
assists and the electrical hatch he says
these are significant steps forward the
thick mental Mata says it's a shame the
Mercedes scrapped the big open vehicle
segment that used to be a fixture in
their range but this new Maybach s650
cabriolet could reverse the decision he
thinks it's a lovely car and it's
definitely going on his wish list but he
says he would offer different rims
gondola inside Porsches new Panamera
executive is 15 centimetres longer than
its previous incarnation which already
had plenty of room but the Panamera for
a hybrid executive is a whopping 5
meters 20 centimeters long of course the
wheelbase is also longer 3 metres tend
to be precise this makes the car more
comfortable for passengers and back
furthermore this hybrid car is very
efficient
[Music]
come on alive either from loame done
Porsches Oliver bluma says the range is
over 50 kilometers and the car bows 462
horsepower so performance is excellent
he says the vehicle is very
environmentally friendly and a lot of
fun too that's y agua Montes would also
like to put the Jaguar I pace concept on
his wish list but not for this Christmas
since it's not due for release till 2018
there's even a spaceship on show in Los
Angeles other the Sun hottest notices it
just as he's saying that his wish list
is already way too long and if he were
to get the spaceship for Christmas where
would he end up putting maybe you should
leave his wishes practical this year in
Los Angeles mr. Fearns on Slayton's for
stylish past and yet splits the hill